hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the forest now the
forest just today as in the day that I'm
playing this game was released up to 1.0
status and none of the words that I just
said made even a little bit of sense in
the context that they were said but that
means that this game is finally in full
release after almost four years of
development it has finally come out so I
decided that I'm gonna take a look and
see what the incredible changes in this
game have been what's going on in it
what kind of new things are there and I
don't know I don't know how far I'm
gonna get probably not nearly enough to
be able to finish this game but there's
apparently a new ending and a reworking
towards getting to that ending not that
I was even remotely close and I don't
even think the last time that I played
this game there was an ending of the
game so I may play this and if you guys
want to see more I could probably stream
it for you if you would like are we
going to crash oh nice moosh hello son
what's that in your hand you didn't have
a toy last time for Timmy okay
the complete guide to survival Oh
[Music]
uh-huh
and we crash and then everybody dies
except for me and my son now probably
not a hundred percent sure but I'm
pretty - oh hi
hello how are you I'm good
could you give me a hand please oh oh no
my sign please no please my son help me
help me not my son yeah fine whatever
all right then I guess I'll crawl my way
back to life Low Energy eat something or
get some rest hungry find something to
eat oh I slept on top of my child's
drawings okay good bold blood hands
how's it going oh yes please I'll take
that thank you
all right good all right anything in the
toilet I need who had booze in the
toilet all right someone who knew how to
live that's who Oh give me that give me
that give me a give me a give me that
give me that give me that all right
we're gonna have Matt okay I just I mean
you're already dead so I guess what does
it matter
hidey-hidey-ho warm okay all right still
good old whoopee oh wait okay wait is
this the animal barrier is this the
poison berry
god damn it there's just no edible
berries in this game I can never get the
right berries okay okay whoa all right
let me gather as much [ __ ] as I can
little it going through all these
people's personal possessions no one's
gonna care throw a tennis ball it's my
life
I'm alone on an island
nobody to love okay see I've no
hayburner Humberto hey you wouldn't you
better run you better run okay well you
don't need to worry about nothing cuz
apparently I'm okay I can't hit I can't
I can't kill these markers I'm sorry I
didn't know that was actually gonna work
I had no no that's probably bad karma to
start I'm sorry everybody I didn't I
didn't mean to do it just because I was
attempting to do it for like five
minutes straight doesn't mean that I
actually thought it would do anything I
mean dysley sorry
okay womp I am off to a bad start laser
you better run you [ __ ]
whoa just me myself and I on this island
no one by my side no one to stop me from
being who I really is out of camp oh I
didn't know we'd be that close to a camp
when we landed if you can call what we
did a landing in the first place hi how
are you I'm neighborhood what do you
have a shoe on your head okay all right
that's no bueno none of this seems to be
very bueno hello Oh camera very nice
okay all right
daga Walker just off take these skulls
in that leg okay can I have the stick
and not the skull as much as I love
juggling skulls really was going for
this stick there more than anything okay
all right cans of gas that's nice okay I
don't know I don't know why there's so
many cans of fuel around here but a
noose great take that well there's been
fun ma'am we'll get out of here before I
run into any the cannibals okay so this
game has been incredibly updated since
the last time I played so honestly I
don't even know where to begin with this
[ __ ] I'm just gonna go into the woods
armed and try to build a base the first
thing I'm gonna do is I'm
try to build a base oh well that's new
okay all right maybe I won't build a
base maybe I won't do that maybe that's
a bad idea maybe I maybe I shan't do
that
I shall not okay all right then do wrong
by wait I can ever wrong thank you I
don't want to be too far away from
actually I know I have no idea what I
want to be far away from her near in the
first place I honestly have no goddamn
idea I'm just kind of going into the
woods I usually like to build a nice
base by the beach but I'll take by this
lovely pond - okay but it's also by
cannibal outpost I don't know if that's
gonna be a problem but if I'm by a pond
that means I can get some fish and if I
can get some fish that means I can keep
some food going you know what I'm saying
yeah you know what I'm saying yeah you
all know what I'm saying
don't ya let me clear out the underbrush
here oh that's kind of cool too because
I can kind of just clear everything out
and make it all nice and pretty like you
know what I mean oh that's nice ooh
mushrooms good bad god damnit of course
it's bad I like how food poisoning in
this game ooh oh oh I don't feel so good
about those mushrooms no other adverse
qualities no epic tire whoa it's about
oh it's Shark Bay okay someone's buried
here I don't know who whoa
oh I know what boat this is I know it's
that boat I just want a Polaroid with a
boat on it there's a boat right there
two plus two equals chicken cassette
number five found do you mean this cuz
that's about there how do I play
cassette how do I do that
hi cassette combined I don't have a
cassette player do I okay all right I
got Timmy photo oh my god Timmy photo
it's quite a creepy photo actually let
me just stare at this photo for a bit
Oh Timmy Timmy I missed you Timmy Timmy
you didn't get to keep your survival
book how will you survive busy TV vision
sorry
lag it let's um let's let's just keep
that for safekeeping okay let's put the
hex back in my hand
sorry Timmy got a got take care of
business okay hope no sharks are gonna
get me cuz I remember sharks are an
eminent threat here I just want to see
what's on the boat please okay those are
Turtles you're fine okay no sharks no
whammies no whammies no Sharky's no
worries I don't think there would be any
sharks in this shallow water right maybe
okay is it porn Oh yotz summer edition
man god damn it alone rainbow alone on
this island with nary a porn in sight
hardly what okay you know whenever I see
a lock I just start swinging I don't
know why they didn't work bye Megan
cross of course it was alright what did
I get like that alright I don't know
what these are
Oh air canisters wait do I need to do
some deep-sea diving
oh I got a cassette player well that's
handy okay combine this with this
yeah
okay all right let's try this
Oh
[Music]
I like it missing Zachary okay well I
can't help the three okay shut up shop
shut up restores the energy oh really
all right shut up I'll say they'll save
that for later I didn't know that I
could sleep here uh what are those are
those my old saves what but what the
last time I played it was last January
that soon what I don't know it saved my
saves I'm not going back to him no way
in hell I'd doubt that everything would
even work if I went back to him oh
there's a head there I didn't notice
that head oh I didn't notice that Oh
are ye okay so this teddy bear if I'm to
make if I'm if I'm to read the room
correctly this teddy bear is haunted and
killed that cuz I feel like I would have
noticed that head there also they got to
pepper shakers and I this place is too
freaky for me to pepper shakers what are
you crazy crazy town anymore I'm gonna
play my tunes back on shore I think I'm
gonna build a base by the beach I
usually like to that's like my that's
like my main digs it's always worked out
for me before so why wouldn't I do it
now actually I'm not gonna do that
because I forgot that they patrol on the
beach I don't remember anymore
I'm going to make my camp here
perfect all this beautiful well this is
beautiful well this is goddamn beautiful
look at this [ __ ] Oh bunny hey how's it
going there bunny well let's look at
this okay craft an item I know about
that nature guide laverra
black twin berry there's a lot of
animals here cool oh this is lovely
oh that's not lovely
there's so many collectibles oh this is
nice basics of survival hunting shelter
easy-peasy basic fire yeah easy-peasy
step 3
edible oval leaves berries indigo color
poisonous black twin berry easy peasy
let's start with the basics huh let's
just start with the basics okay wait I
need that okay let's build a basic
hunting shelter we're gonna put it right
in the shady way T right here huh is it
busy
need another rock give me a rock rocks
yes thank you sticks sticks and log
clunk oh that's satisfy it's a nice bump
on that come on come on keep going well
I got click every time come on
oh it's good that's a nice one oh yeah
oh that's good stuff where you going
where you going buddy I'll go ahead and
get started the next one
womp womp womp womp äj-- wind blow
wobble lumpy wobble oh yeah flaw we know
the rider and wumbo whim Wham
waffle wobble whoa look blah there we go
okay give me you I still don't think
there's a danger of it hitting me on the
head but you know maybe maybe there is
okay Blanc Blanc wait okay log ok Blanc
oh oh that's nice oh that's nice look at
this where's [ __ ] where's [ __ ] luggage
eventually I'm gonna make the entire
clearing is where my base is gonna be so
that's why I'm not building in there
right now why am okay give me that
yeah yeah yeah oh I'm full okay all
right Oh birdie bird feather yes please
okay so what I need now is I need to
start making the things for small cabin
yeah not that we need a guard water
collector that's nice rabbit cage okay
stick holder but let's do this stick
holder and the log holder in the rock
holder let's do those we're gonna need
okay this is just preliminary this is
preliminary pearl this is just pull up a
luminary okay can you stop accelerating
when I don't need you to thank you okay
that's stick holder right there
okay and stick stick stick to draw
sticks to hold the sticks huh oh yeah
okay see this is what's cool about the
game it's it's it's so intricately
immersive like it does take a long time
to actually get any what get anywhere in
the game but it does it does make it
really interesting along the way like oh
they're gonna happen am I gonna die and
then you all are like ah it's a
markiplier of course he's gonna [ __ ]
die he's an idiot done all right give me
the logs
give me those logs come here log e
alright log good thing I can really leap
with these logs alright stop Jeff okay
how's this log get out over here I have
this log before I don't remember all
right good job me oh hi um you're here
early
uh they'll never find me they'll never
find me oh they found me okay alright
that's a problem well I'm not ready to
face off with you guys Robert Robert
arabica um alrighty then can you leave
me alone did you leave me alone
yeah you can leave me alone around
little bunnies going into the ocean
little bunnies going for a swim can I
bunny ruthless rock money okay did you
leave my camp
are you gone yet can I go back home I
mean not home I mean this is my home now
I've become very accustomed to the ways
of this world I am the master of my
environment and you do leave did you all
decide to kindly [ __ ] off okay good and
get real good okay at some point I'm
gonna need water I don't have any I'll
wait actually you're the pond okay okay
okay what hi okay all right that's weird
can I drink that drink from this slurp
that's a weirdest symbol I've ever seen
for drinking is weird I don't like the
lips on that
who don't like the lips what witness
what's going on here what do I not like
the water the bad water the bad water
beds bad water hey hey hey
hey lady I'll [ __ ] you up lap lap why
are you laughing okay that was weird
I'll take your teeth as a little bizarre
all right well back to drinking slurp
ahh refreshing Oh covered in blood
gross
apparently this waters no bueno oh wait
no I'm full on water I thought the blue
meter was the water that's just my
energy okay I need to sleep and or make
a fire I'm not sure which let's just go
to sleep
that's just sleep sleep how about we
sleep sleeps good
I like sleep alright what else we got
here oh it's still dark
alright let's build a fire or something
like a basic fire a bonfire fire pit
let's build a fire pit loophole night
night night we deserve something nice
you know right there okay we need more
rock and stick I can't see [ __ ] there's
another Rock right there how convenient
another rock perfect why did that have a
head symbol I don't want it I really
don't want to I don't want to cook ahead
I could get a leg though just leg put
the money on that make it rain a bit
let's see oh wait let's put some money
on the areolas put money let's see oh I
could put my meat on there
boink and a boink okay alright and then
put
money in there that's cooking up real
nice alright ok bye birdie fine [ __ ] you
I need to make a rock holder I need a
place to put my rocks if there's one
thing ok armor that's weird ok skin Rack
bone basket everybody needs a bone
basket you ask my my Pappy always told
me somebody need to be bone basket Rock
holder alright we're gonna put you right
there lump lump I need some sticks but I
don't why you know I'm they ain't gonna
go in there was this all about sleep
sleeping okay we're going north at
happens we're gonna ignore the noise
that's right you deserve that
give me your teeth huh who wants
something these guys are easier to kill
oh hey whoa okay alright how about no
you don't even look human well wow
there's a lot e bomb oh [ __ ] you up I'm
by the light of my match come on
ah give me your teeth oh yeah I'll take
your teeth
yeah I'll steal your teeth yeah you
better you better be Scott Reggie your
teeth give me your teeth your teeth here
we gonna do now then you don't have the
power of your teeth you are your teeth
give your teeth Hey oh there's more for
you more more if you want to give me
your teeth huh come on ow
no how about how do you give a nice
tooth donation teeth teeth can I have
your teeth where's your teeth oh you
don't have teeth oh okay I see how it is
where'd the last one go oh hey there it
is I knock your tooth out oh I knocked
another tooth out I'm taking that tooth
yeah that's right yeah give me your
teeth flap there's another one out there
anybody can I have my meat gonna eat
that Oh slurp oh yeah you're gonna watch
me this with all the teeth I found I am
on fire can I not be on fire I'm still
on fire why am i okay I'm gonna run to
the water I guess okay never mind I'm
not on fire anymore all right Noah that
was fun
glad I did that oh how are the [ __ ] are
you know took your teeth now okay that's
bad no no no come on how the [ __ ] I
didn't get hit at all from those guys
and this guy gives me three shots after
he fell down and went oh oh oh no not
this I forgot
I forgot how annoying this was no no no
no come on now oh well if that wasn't
bad enough I'd best not look down
oh there we go well their mistake huh
all right let's cut it ourselves out of
here chop my I got like I'm tied up by
my legs I'm like oh we'll the only way
out is to chop my own legs off there's
no other way around it let's do that
packin
thank you some sticks out of this oh
please tell me I can't leave baby cribs
were these alright that's weird I got
some coins this a jealous God punishes
the parents fault on their children oh
hello oh hello oh hello
I got a compass I got a map really all
right I'm sorry I you've all right so
yeah I'm full on skulls I've got enough
skulls I used to think I could have more
skulls by I'm good I'm good on skulls
whoa down why not down why not I like
down sounds good yeesh man they really
improved all the details on this game
like the little subtle details that make
it something have been more terrifying
I am I hear someone
let's put my laid out
oh I don't know what I hear but I don't
like it
nice ass okay horrible horrible horrible
horrible horrible horrible horrible I
don't know why I feel the need to be
quiet when this game doesn't interact
with my microphone in Airway but I'm
still like maybe not okay please tell me
this is not the way I came here and
there's the way out okay I think it's a
way out okay should I go the way of the
glowing skull that seems safe okay I'll
go that way I don't know if that's good
it's my map doing me any good
oh this is terrifying this is much
scarier than it was in the past
I see I have no idea what's going on and
I don't like it
oh maybe what is this is that a squeeze
hold yeah it's a squeeze hole I love me
a good squeeze hole there's a quiet
place oh just let the movie I hate it I
[Music]
heard this dippy step in the darkness
that's a leg okay that's a walk
oh oh oh gotta run I can't run as goo
goo pee oh oh my god the babies they did
maybe cages oh my god is right behind me
I don't know everything seems way too
calm for how much death I'm in alright
hmm oh good I think we're getting out of
here finally probably oh look
suitcases listen this wampum open cuz
now's the tile can nevermind no I won't
then I guess what's that what did I find
a cos a cool gasps perfect I don't know
why all this is here but okay I got some
circuit boards I guess where am I please
tell me there's nothing oh god I'm so
hungry and thirsty and tired I just want
to go home I'm not cut out for the
forest I can't survive here I can't
survive it's impossible
Oh mio was there please tell me it can't
climb a rope I doubt that very much but
okay okay I think I'm getting out of
here holy [ __ ] that's terrifying
that's terrifying that's so scary that's
so scary
[Laughter]
okay Wow let's never do that again I am
oh there's my kid well oh boy okay all
right then don't like these bodies being
here let's get you here Moses get you
here this is good all right let me get a
drink of water
just really Slurpee blur pee I need some
food and badly
oh god that water is no good huh okay
buddy come here oh [ __ ] I'm never gonna
catch a bunny not like this anyway Oh
lizard hello okay oh maybe I'll kick me
I'm gonna get lucky what take this all
right got that okay take that ooh bunny
head all right I got a good
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh boy oh no let's cook some funny meat
ha let's see about coal what is this
bunny still of a head off I've got many
questions none of them are being
answered let's see if I can kill a bird
nope okay alright then I'll have bunny
meat soon enough oh boy that is a that
is a startling discovery I really like
this game this game's hard as [ __ ] but
goddamn some of them of its kind of
special ah good one my rock good my one
rock that's all I needed
let me try to find it a friend once
these rocks get to Mayton I'll have all
the rocks I need alright two rocks
excellent there's another rock stick
Rock well if I chop into this big rock
and I get some small rocks nope okay
stick I need to go wash and then my uh
then my rabbit will be ready probably oh
that's not the way to the pond you know
I'm a wash later I don't care if I get
an infection at this point I'll just
bear with the infection I'll just lived
through it it's fine another rock
somebody's sleeping on all these rocks
here
alright let's just let's smooth let's
news says lay our head to rest snoozy
Busey alright oh good I'm sure this
isn't burnt to crisp from a tiny amount
of hay [ __ ] with me oh look at that
moon go huh so I'm weird about that well
I don't want to put the leg there so I'm
not gonna
alright this terrifying now it's night
okay this is going
early all right Foundation custom custom
oh boy bone fence treehouse I would love
I love trio's sounds great I don't have
to worry about these [ __ ] utility Oh
targets tree sap collector and that
sounds nice crane crane whoa look at all
the [ __ ] ceilings skull lamp look at all
the [ __ ] Oh head drop wait yeah a little
make a head trophy yeah wait okay all
right let's put this right let's see can
I put it on my perfect okay all right
we're just need a trophy Oh my body no
my bunny head is here we go wait wait
yes yes an axe that is not that's not
sharp stick Oh spear I don't wait up
great spear bones okay don't have bones
cloth okay all right whatever I got
teeth can I do something with teeth
anyway I got a spear that's what I
needed
okay so I can fish with this watch this
[ __ ] you guys watching you guys watching
this [ __ ] you better be watching this
[ __ ] shits about to get real should I
eat these not good for me
apparently these are good for me okay I
need a fish I'm not gonna be able to
find a fish am I
hmm well I'm boned okay why all right
give me your teeth oh [ __ ]
I'm gonna take her teeth Oh take your
teeth thank you
okay I think that was the last straggler
I think that was the last that was the
one that killed me before so now he's
gone so tough [ __ ] okay all right then
easy enough I guess
oh let's eat some bars I forgot that we
actually had snack bars that is much
better it's still night which is a
problem but at least we can see some
[ __ ] okay I'm making double the double
the holders double the holders for
double the fun and eventually I'm gonna
get all these logs that I toss down the
night I'm gonna get them back to my base
but I want to be better about
organizational [ __ ] you know the
[ __ ] that I don't care about I want to
be better about that because that's how
you be a good whatever
gamer person Cuban yeah all right so
we're full on rocks we're not full
unload it's dark you we're not full on
logs pop okay more logs I don't toss
down more trees than this yeah that's a
lot of log we're gonna need a lot more
than that if we're almost day
please Sutton save me from the night
thank goodness gravy there's more logs
but I don't have another log holder
gotta get more sticks who knew I needed
summon a goddamn sticks actually I knew
that from the very last time that I
played this game I remember needing an
incredible amount of sticks Hey much
badder what is this oh [ __ ] never mind
destroyed it well then matter any it was
part of nature and therefore deserves to
be burned wait no that doesn't seem
right yeah whatever it's good enough
there we go hard
oh just a little delicious it's pretty
vicious that is pretty goddamn vicious
all right let's put the meat on there
whoa there's a nightmare of a whoop
we've got food we got shelter we got
good [ __ ] going on here okay so this is
good this is good there's a good or a
good start
it's not a great start but a good start
okay oh it's beautiful
brand-new day new opportunities my son's
missing everybody I know and love
probably thinks I'm dead my wife is
moving let's build a log let's build a
log rabbit-skin don't I have a rabbit
skin I could build a rabbit skin let's
put it right Wow I made a rabid skin for
malagos like a nicer hat on my house you
know a house yeah there's a beautiful
day Oh everyone's running through the
bird come on bird every time it happens
I'm shocked and surprised god dammit I
need to put more [ __ ] on here give me
that
okay how about more light put another
whatever you have it on here meat yeah
that's good okay
and with that Oh bards came to the wrong
house I should feel bad about that but
it's about survival that's survival
that's all it is okay anyway so I'm
gonna save and I think I might end this
here this is super fun I forgot how much
fun this actually could be and how hard
it is to actually get going the long
game I don't know but apparently I've
got a map now which is awfully
convenient for exploring and literally
everything I am at the very south end of
everything here but anyway that'll do it
for now so thank you everybody
much for watching let me know what you
thought down the comments below if you
want to see more of this let me know
there as well thanks again and as always
I will see you in the next video
[Music]